mais loge plus
ah ah
[Musique]
dans le match des parcs c'est la panique
au far-west phil keen d'ovins watch
personne ne peut me teste un point chaud
briolet les poches pleines de billets 10
mois ce qui t'a paris et moi j'ai six
coups dans le par est yervoy sétois rien
à craindre j'ai mis mon gilet
pare-balles train je te met du plomb
dans les freins air de piano bastringue
c'est le portrait il me suffit d'une
balle pour te faire tomber ma poule yann
brys la bouteille à jesse may cry jeudi
plus vite que ton nom est petite tête
est mise à prix
c'est trop de balles vous êtes tout
juste assez bien fait à la loyale une
dernière volonté pour anderson avec tes
potes torstensson et laisse moi te
rappeler que tout le monde personne ses
coutures ap
j'ai juste eu mal au crâne qui payait ma
tournée tu veux 100 mg près de calais
tout piqué à clint eastwood et à la
gueule d'une mascotte de mode et
facebook
quand tu essayes de camper entre pairs à
l'odeur tenté de kick it / ap rome à
youtube à caen pour un cow boy mais tu
seras mon cobaye tranchant comme un
scalpel mais lyriques sont les talent et
si tu green medic je t'emmène aux
urgences pour mieux te défoncer la
gueule sans ordonnance
pour le combat
les sublimes le plus tard et 2
mais encore là comme ici les deux balles
et de coups bas
sublime le plus tard et de la vie
en tout surtout moi
ok ok ok
c'est un fanni le décompte a commencé la
dengue aux tic tac
tous les corps ont attaqué mon flow
quitté très vite et je vais te craquer
[Musique]
quand tu vois mort de matti effet dans
son slip du flip ultrahd tu craches je
suis à la plaque
tu pensais que j'étais cas quand la
caisse je t'éclate combat éthique et se
détend et les membranes des mines au toc
toc qui est là c'est moi j'ai mis des
grenats quant aux phoques
jean boiteux et d'hommes exit été pris
pour l'antarctique des gains de court de
pacotille backbeat buffo vers un bouffon
tout court mais ferme-là quoi tu sers
été vue avec ta jambe en bois et au flou
on mouille je vais t'écraser tastan
fatah coup de mou n'est guère mais je te
crie au génie de cryogénie quand je te
brise l'ifri et ça ton testament gassant
tu va nourrir d'or qui sera puni en
glaçon dans un mojito prêt pour le
combat
[Musique]
kuba reina me laisse ultime les plus
tarés de l'addip les meilleurs
cinquièmes journées encore la traque
toujours prêt pour le combat
ici l'est de baqouba on l a mis 10
ultime
le plus tard
enfin surtout moi
quoi de coûts dans tous les sens et à
contretemps et c'est aussi pourquoi tu
n'as pas le temps je vais te frapper de
sa dette tu te fais péter qu'il est tout
petit calcul de télé te flinguer tout
prix mais se sont inquiétés des dommages
aux ténors msci tard ap - nul secondes
et j'ai eu le temps de me faire chier si
tu aimerais quand ça va vite ta mort tu
va l'apprécier des pêches dans ta gueule
oh oui ça y en aura mac la fureur du
dragon je te dis sayonara les puncheurs
vivent toujours dans le michelin
l'expert en balistique du balises quand
je débarque tpu soeur moi je m'en bats
les sectes ton temps est compté regardez
au courant quand tu entends les waka
waka c'est ki moon sur une cible en
mouvement quand il fait appel je te
décroche la pomme d'adam plus fort que
guillaume tell j'suis pas du bidon si je
transfère pas le coeur brisé
elle ne sert de courir suffit d'avoir
visé
non mais
m
[Musique]
voire car elles sont